وفي اتصال هاتفيا مع رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
قال رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي رئيس جمهوريه
جزر القمر غزالي عثمان الاتحاد سيطلق
مبادره لمعالجه الوضع في السودان وانه
يامل ان يقبلها طرف النزاع وحسب بيان
لمجلس السياده السوداني فان رئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي بحث مع البرهان خلال الاتصال
جهود حل الازمه وداعا الى التهدئه ووقف
التصعيد
من جهته قال الرئيس الكيني وليم بروتو انه
بحث مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
سبوله تخفيف الازمه الانسانيه وانهاء
الصراع في السودان واضاف ان الوضع
الانساني في السودان يزداد سوءا اوضح ان
كينيا ستعمل بشكل وثيق مع الولايات
المتحده وايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي
والوكالات الامميه والدول الصديقه لتنسيق
الاستجابه الانسانيه اللازمه